Yeah,
no,
we have progressed in the gay rights
movement,
but we haven't progressed as a result of
government policies are certainly not
leadership at the federal level.
I think what's remarkable is that the
progress we've made,
despite the opposition from the federal
government or some of the state
governments,
it would have been unthinkable to me.
I'm 44 years old.
Two weeks ago when I was growing up,
I would've thought impossible for gay
people to marry.
Now we have it in many states,
including in some of the most remarkable
states that you could actually be
pronounced husband and husband and wife
and wife.
You can get buried in Dubuque Buca.
You can't get married in Chelsea or in
San Francisco.
Frankly.
The fact that we've made progress in
places like that and Connecticut,
Massachusetts,
New Hampshire,
I think that speaks volumes about the
power and the dynamism and the gay
rights community that we see still the
federal government officials mumble when
it comes to questions around gay rights,
that these are not equal rights of
ordinary American citizens.
We saw the Obama administration submit
this brief in the,
in,
uh,
to defend the defense of marriage act
and indefensible piece of law that was
signed by President Clinton,
uh,
shows you that in fact,
democrats can sometimes not be a lot
better than Republicans and some of the
key civil rights,
civil liberties issues.
And here you had the Obama
administration filed this brief
defending the law in some of the most
disgusting rhetoric and language.
Uh,
I understand the fact that justice
department has to defend the laws
enacted by Congress,
but the way they did so in that brief
was really offensive to many gay,
lesbian people across this country.
And the fact that they had such a
teenager that they couldn't realize that
the way they were going to defend this
law was going to be in a way that would
really infuriate gay,
lesbian people are across the country.
Who thought that we had embarked upon a
very different time in our nation's
history.
And I think it's great that President
Obama actually says the words gay and
lesbian.
Uh,
I think it was notable that the Naacp
Convention,
he talked about gay people still know
having to civil rights and I think it's
great that he had this ceremony
commemorating the 40th anniversary of
stonewall at the White House,
but frankly talk is cheap and there's
only so long that a very eloquent and
very thoughtful and very charismatic
president will be able to get away on
talk alone.
Frankly,
the policies and the outcomes and the
decisions of that government has to
measure up to the talk that both led him
into the White House.
And that is still allowing him to lead
the public in very significant ways.
At one point,
we all turned off for when people's
actions don't measure up to their words.
Uh,
I don't think anyone legitimately can
say that.
Don't ask,
don't tell us worked.
Even the wife of the author of that,
uh,
the terrible policy,
a rat on a campaign,
it was a mistake to put,
don't ask,
don't tell in place that you created a
witch hunt in the military that you can
be gay.
You just can't ask about it.
You can't tell anyone about it.
But if you tell someone or someone asks
about it,
then you could still be pushed out of
the military.
It's,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
They promise to,
uh,
to undo.
Don't ask,
don't tell.
They are the bomb administration,
uh,
but they're saying now that they will,
they'll get to it and they're sweet.
They're sweet old time.
Uh,
it's really quite different if you're an
openly gay or lesbian,
serving in the military and putting your
life on the line for our country,
and yet your government can discriminate
against you and you could lose your job
even as you,
you lay down your life for your country.
You could still be kicked out from that,
that posts or that,
that position.
And frankly there is no.
There's no reason why we ought to wait.
The,
it's not as if we're going to be able to
fix the economy or the healthcare or the
environment or even these wars in the
near future.
And that frankly,
social change is not a sequential piece.
This is not like your college
prerequisites.
We,
you take economics 100,
one before you go to economics due to,
oh one.
Frankly,
these issues all have to be dealt with
aggressively and the idea that we will
wait to deal with them just shows in
fact that they're not a huge priority
for this administration the way we had
hoped and that in the way that many had
voted for them to bring about that
change.
I find it remarkable that increasingly
the Obama administration is is
sustaining withering attacks,
not just from civil libertarians about
human rights and civil liberties,
but from the gay community,
from the women's community,
from young people,
from the antiwar activist.
We.
Those were the.
Those were the base that often created
the seedbed that got him elected and yet
some of the major issues that I think
propelled so many young people and so
many different people to vote for this
president are now other ones that we
find on the back burner I think is
actually not a very good political
agenda.
It doesn't take a lot for a 25 year old
to become disenchanted.
Once again with the political process
and you know frankly when when folks
turned out in record numbers and gave
record amounts of money is because they
want to see swift decisive change and
that has yet to come about,
well certainly giving the full
protection of health benefits to federal
government employees,
which is not what he's done a would be
an important first step.
You're look at President Obama is like a
ceo of a major corporation,
right?
It's just like as if you were the CEO of
Walt Disney or apple and if you're
concerned about the health and wellbeing
of your employees,
you want to protect them.
You want to protect them and their
families.
I think it is remarkable that this
president has said that even though a
CEO,
the government workers of the United
States of America,
that he won't provide healthcare
benefits for same sex partners who work
a for with the federal government.
That's something he could do.
That's something he ought to do.
Frankly.
If apple can get around to it or Nike
can get around to it and Walt Disney,
you can get around to it.
I think the CEO of United States of
America can get around to that too.
It doesn't need congress.
It could just implement that.
Uh,
that was also another misstep on the gay
rights front.
Uh,
you Adama you had the mumbling on don't
ask,
don't tell.
You had the lack of providing full
healthcare benefits for federal
government employees.
People begin to scratch their heads and
wondering whether or not we're going to
see the type of change we were hoping
for.
And that's the type of change that the
president can bring about.
He could also use the bully pulpit to be
very clear around marriage.
And in fact,
the president has said in his books and
his public speaking,
that he struggles with the idea around
marriage for lesbian and gay people.
Not that hard a,
frankly,
we don't have the same protections as
straight people have.
No,
he is protected by the law of the
presence protected by law.
He's got two beautiful daughters and a
wonderful first lady who's his wife.
And the law protects their family,
uh,
protects them from discrimination,
protects them in case anything were to
go wrong with either one of the parents,
gay people across this country don't
have the benefit of those legal
protections.
And no matter how much they say they
want to treat us as equal citizens and
give us a full rights,
the fact is,
unless you move and you implement on
those rights,
it's,
it's just rhetoric.
It's just a hortatory language.
Uh,
and frankly,
it,
the time has come for bold,
decisive leadership and seen it in
states all across this country.
Frankly,
Massachusetts as married gay people now
for over a year and some months.
And the institution of marriage,
I don't think there's any weaker and
mess Massachusetts.
And is that.
It was three years ago.
We've seen it in Connecticut.
And frankly,
decisive,
clear action from the federal
government,
I think is essential.
Unnecessary.
And it's still a.